would you date someone who's trans would
you date someone who's black
would you date someone who's fat would
you date someone who's disabled now
honestly i don't know what your answer
is to those questions
but i've met a surprising number of
people who would say no to all or at
least some of them
yeah i'd definitely say no to something
that's an older song
argument is that it's just a preference
and that you can't control who you're
attracted to i think most of the time
that this is brought up it's in regards
to race
i'll link to a couple really good videos
in the description about racial dating
preferences
but in this video i want to talk about
our other biases let's start with trans
people would you date a trans person
no no honestly think about it for a
second
no no okay got your answer
no i didn't need a second
thank you well if you said no i'm sorry
but that's pretty discriminatory
i'm done where you going did you
[ __ ] this [ __ ] there's no discrimination
what i said i wouldn't date a person
that has a penis
because i had a penis what about how the
penis because they got everything taken
off oh that's different
i'm just not afraid of penis okay but
even if they used to have a penis oh
my that's not a strand that's a woman
that's not a woman that's a woman that
can't have kids
yes whichever one plus some situation
i think the main concern that people
have in regards to dating a trans person
is that they won't have the genitals
that they expect because we associate
penises with men and vaginas with women
some people think they could never date
a trans man with a vagina or a trans
woman with a penis
gay men often pride themselves on being
disgusted by vaginas and the same goes
for lesbian women with penises but i
don't think they're innate at all my
point is
we have implicit biases that we were
raised with or that we developed over
time
the reason you don't like penises is
because society tells you
you shouldn't like penises that's what
i'm saying so are you saying that
gay people aren't born this way that
they're learning to
crave [ __ ] and dislike vaginas that
there's something
unnatural about gay people society we
taught is that what you're saying
yeah you need to refer to me with my
proper pronoun you know
i don't feel attraction towards that
genital
because it's naturally ingrained in me
it's equivalent of saying you're
socially ingrained to being gay by men
not wanting
vaginas and being gay you're saying that
these guys are being discriminatory
if i accept the fact that gay men are
gay because of birth and all of that
stuff and they're not being taught
then how can you tell me that i'm being
taught to be straight and had taught to
want a vagina
if i see someone that is cis and is
dating a trans
i'm not gonna be like what are you doing
nah do you boo boo
i don't care someone says to me i would
never date a black person
okay okay personally me i prefer to date
black women
go it's not it's not a discriminatory
thing these people there are certain
cultural aspects that i prefer
that i normally find in black women in
the same way some men would prefer to
date someone who's not trans as a result
of finding certain
physical features and certain upbringing
features that only if someone was born
as a human would have
but i think that people are more than
their genitals i think that you could
feel attraction to someone without
knowing what's between their legs and if
you were to say that you're only
attracted to people with vaginas or
people with penises
it really feels like you're reducing
people just to their genitals
that's not what they're saying now
whatever argument what they're saying is
if i want to build a long-lasting
relationship with somebody or have a
sexual relationship with certain people
there are certain things i would look
for for example me if i met somebody
that didn't want to give blow jobs i
probably would stop seeing that person
some people don't want to get married or
date people below the
height of five foot five am i to tell
them that they're wrong for doing that
no that's just their preference and it
is shallow and it's okay i don't give a
[ __ ]
get what you want but don't tell me that
because i don't want to date trans
people because they have a penis or used
to have a penis that i'm somehow
transphobic that's ridiculous
yo you want to eat that spider no i
don't want to eat a spider why don't you
want to eat a spider man
i don't eat bucks [ __ ] like you got
arachnophobia is that what it is so what
it is huh
you would have put a spot in your mouth
the same way you wouldn't put a dick in
your mouth
it's just a dick if you see a lady
and she happens to have a dick you don't
want to put that dick in your mouth
you transphobic you scared you scared
huh huh huh
huh
the idea of transphobia denotes that i'm
afraid
of something i'm not afraid of trans
people i just wouldn't date them really
feels like you're reducing people just
to their genitals you're kind of
objectifying them but you're thinking of
them more as
genitals than objects so i guess you're
kind of genitalifying them
if you met someone who was extremely
attractive had a great personality but
didn't have the genitals that you wanted
you might be surprised to find that it
isn't a deal breaker to you
it's not it's your brain and the way
that we talk about potentially dating
trans people has a lot in common with
the way we discuss
other preferences saying that you're not
attracted to fat people isn't innate
it's informed by a society that tells
you that being thin
is ideal no listen
there is an evolutionary basis in
finding people that are physically fit
women like bigger larger men not because
they're just powerful
but because it meant something for their
survival so those were the these
traits that they found desirable fat
people have always been
seen as bad since the dawn of men for
a number of reasons either glutinous
reasons for disease reasons
you're at way more health risks that
doesn't make for an ideal partner if you
are
substantially overweight i think a lot
of people want to blame a lot of things
on society not understanding the
biological impact
and evolution has on us as human beings
and i think that's just people thinking
that they're way more important than
they actually are they think they can
control everything
and you can't and the media you consume
is bombarding you with messages that
skinny is beautiful and fat is ugly if
you find someone attractive and really
enjoy spending time with them
there's no reason why their weight
should be a factor i met somebody
they they ride a bike i have to consider
the danger of that does it mean that i'm
making the deal breaker no but these are
things i take into consideration
as you should with your partner if you
care about them you should look at their
weight especially if they're getting
fatter and fatter to a point where it's
a detriment to their health
you should definitely take that into
consideration am i crazy
yes why because you're still watching
this piece of [ __ ]
we have to dissect it no we don't when
people say dumb [ __ ]
it's all been dumb it's all been dumb
that's crazy i know thank you very much
and lastly let's talk about disabled
people disabilities come in a very wide
range from being deaf to being in a
wheelchair to only having one arm
and i think it's pretty ridiculous to
say that you couldn't be attracted to
any person who has any of those
disabilities disabilities can happen to
anyone someone you're extremely
attracted to today
could become disabled tomorrow and that
shouldn't make your attraction them
disappear though if it does it might not
be because of them but rather because
you have some preconceived ideas about
disabled people that are just inaccurate
and harmful unsurprisingly this is
another case of the media telling you
that a certain group
isn't attractive well there's nobody
telling me that women in wheelchairs are
ugly
i've never seen an ad i'd be like deaf
people they're kind of [ __ ]
that's not something that passes on tv
you just recognize that there's
difficulties with dating people who are
disabled and you can overcome those
and fight through that relationship the
same way if i meet somebody with a child
that is definitely something you have to
consider when you date them
so this idea that you know these are
preconceived notions that people see
difficulties
are difficulties and it's it's the
equivalent of you saying
you don't see color you're
you're you're you're minimizing other
people's experiences if you're going to
date someone who's black you have to
take that into consideration understand
what that means if i met a girl and she
wanted to pretend like my
my skin color didn't matter i'd be like
no but you do have to understand it
because you have to understand how i
navigate the world the difficulty of
stuff i deal with
so that's why a lot of what this person
is saying is dangerous stuff
so by working on ourselves to dispel
that idea we can make the world a more
welcoming and loving place
for everybody no matter how they look
this video is a part of my feminism with
riley series that i'm doing in
collaboration with everyday feminism a
website dedicated to helping you stand
up to and break down everyday oppression
i don't know what to tell you this video
was full of misinformation the person
had no solutions because
she was making up data information
that's not real
and uh science doesn't back up what she
says so
[ __ ] so that's it for today's video be
sure to share
like subscribe comment leave comments
because we we read it but we never reply
if you guys want to follow us we got a
youtube instagram patreon all that stuff
you know
share it tell them
we also have a sunday open mic that
happens every week here in montreal
details below
other than that see y'all soon next week
you know a dollar makes me holler baby